in the lobby of the headquarters from
Ramsey solutions Robert and Lindy are
with us hey guys how are you today
pretty good good to have you guys now
where do you live
so a living Queensland Australia so just
west of Brisbane where I'm stationed
currently so you just dropped by
Nashville to see us yeah just a random
stop boy yeah it's just uh I think this
could be the farthest travel to do an
inlet Lobby debt-free scream I think you
get the award that was the goal yeah
okay it's like 20-something hours 25
hours probably to get here yeah so 13
hours to LA from Brisbane and then we
had a nice long round trip through
Seattle boy Seattle okay so so how long
have you been in the States for days
okay so you've had time to adjust a
little bit so the jet LAG's not still
kicking your body oh yeah we left the
kids with family in California Lindy's
parents live there okay that's so uh I'm
pretty sure my radio shows don't show up
over there maybe the podcast is that yes
no we got the podcast okay I'll listen
to that most days okay I'll get the
Bluetooth into stereos yeah just the
high tunes then huh okay yeah we have
our I tuned account set in America
because I don't think we can get it from
the Australia right that's exactly right
okay very cool you guys well I'm and
that's how you connect it up with us
yeah I knew about you before I moved
okay um I kind of did it half-heartedly
I did move oh so you're from California
I'm from Tulare oh okay very cool so how
much debt have you paid off there's a
hundred and forty-one thousand okay is
that American or Australian mix of ice
okay we spread the love around okay how
long did it take 41 months all right and
you're a range of income during that
time actuated a fair bit so he had about
a hundred and forty we started off at
Lindy had a southern job loss
so that quickly took us back down to 75
and we got we're a bit lost we didn't
know really what we were going to do so
we both started up little businesses
even though I was serving we were able
to boost our income back up with me
doing some hours and Lindy picking up a
little side business and he can nod off
and that got us back up to around 100
good deal good deal love it love it so
uh what kind of debt was the hundred and
forty one thousand hit everything yeah a
lot so there was a there was a house
that Lindy had at a rental in Arizona
mm-hmm
and then we just had consumer debt car
loans credit cards my university loan
yes the regular stuff really yeah did
you sell the house in Arizona I did and
what did it bring I was just around 95
okay so that helped a bunch yeah it was
about a hundred one hundred and forty
one right gotcha okay so what happened
41 months ago that puts you on this
journey to get out of debt that's when I
moved to Australia uh-huh yeah I met
Lindy while I was stationed over here
and we decided to drag it back home with
me and yeah yeah we went from there that
just shook up at both our worlds yeah I
just I didn't want to be in debt and not
have the ability to get on a plane if I
needed to but there was a family
emergency or mmm-hmm I needed R&R or
something so what made you guys decide
to work this system the podcast how'd
you find our podcast how do you because
you knew before we can be border with
her and then she's had the Financial
Peace University and she said oh look I
really like this plan and Wow she's a
pretty smart woman so I thought I'll
listen to her and I just played the
their CDs in my car driving to and from
work I've got about a 40 to 45 minute
commute out on the base so yeah we just
I just listened to that got got through
all the lessons there and went yeah
let's go okay so you should station
didn't base or your Australian military
yeah Royal Australian Air Force okay Wow
thank you for your service to that
country that's awesome
thank you very cool how does it feel now
tonight
any death it's surreal yeah we thought
it kind of comes in waves yes sort of
you realize this you get those little
bits of freedom like like this trip like
we're paid for it in cash had savings
like we finished paying off our debt a
few months ago and just the money we had
once we weren't paying money to anyone
else we were just able to go oh geez we
can we can just pay cash for this thing
yeah yeah originally we just planned for
him and I to come out here and then I
was saving your put it away and I was
like well we're gonna clear our debt
I mean we're gonna clear our goal pretty
quick so we have all three kids out here
no okay airfare is not cheap yeah and
they got to see mom and dad huh yeah the
grandpa Graham oh yeah yeah cool neat
very neat so what do you tell people
when they ask how you paid off a hundred
and forty 1041 months well we tell them
about you that's for sure
just follow the plan like it's it's just
practical it's it's basic that it works
it's just that good old kiss principle
it's just simple keep it simple just
keep chugging along no matter how hard
it gets and those things that you want
you've just got to go oh wait and I'll
get it yeah we get them just looking
into the future rather than just next
week makes such a difference so how long
have you been in the military I've
served 12 years now okay so the
discipline that's in the military how
much did that assist you in having
discipline in this area probably
probably a fair bit yeah Lyn deal
what's it's game on its game on okay
that's cool yeah yeah so you kind of
create a monster there Lindy yeah a good
monster though it's very good
congratulations you two
very well done and we're honored to have
you be our I know you're our first
Australian in the studio now we've had
call ins but it's a first the first one
in the studio and by far the longest
travel today Kelly Daniels keeps up with
the stuff and she was telling me at the
break she said this is they get the
award for the longest travel so very
cool yes all the way from Queensland
Australia so very fun and of course
we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's retire
inspired books signed
by him for you and let's take you to the
retire inspired number one national
bestseller take you the next chapter in
your story from debt-free to wealthy and
I'll be able to live and give like no
one else which is the goal here so very
good congratulations you two very proud
of you thanks Dave and thanks for taking
the trouble to come all the way here man
that's very cool all right it's Robert
and Len B Queensland Australia a hundred
and forty-one thousand dollars paid off
in 41 months making 140 down to 75 then
back up to a hundred count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
awesome it's very fun very fun hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show